Go to Stufftoblowyourmind.com to enter the
Science Awards contest and a chance to win
a $10,000 college sponsorship.
sponsored by BASF, THE chemical company.
Water + air + sun = jet fuel?
Well... yeah.
That's a thing we can say now!
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and we did
it!
We have successfully created jet fuel, out
of thin air.
And by we, I mean a team of highly specialized
chemists.
Obviously.
Researchers from the SOLAR-JET Project have
found a way to create kerosene, using only
water, air, and sunlight.
And if you don't think that's amazing, then
I don't know what to tell you.
The basic idea is this: they combine water
and carbon dioxide, and then use simulated,
concentrated sunlight to convert it into syngas,
which is a gas made up of hydrogen, carbon
monoxide, and oxygen.
They then used the Fischer-Tropsch process,
which is a chemical process invented in Germany
in the 1920s, to convert the syngas into kerosene,
so it can be used as fuel.
It's a simple idea, right?
Yes, but it's been hard to accomplish until
now, for 2 main reasons.
One - the dissociation of carbon dioxide and
water only happens at extremely high temperatures,
around 4,000 degrees F. So to achieve that,
they used a high-flux solar simulator that
mimics the output from a solar concentrator.
So it gets insanely hot.
Problem solved.
The other issue, is that the Fischer--Tropsch
process, which converts the syngas into kerosene
- can cause a massive explosion if the oxygen
isn't completely removed from the syngas first.
This problem was solved by using ceria, which
is a chemical compound that releases oxygen
when heated above 2,700 degrees F. So when
you heat up the ceria, all of the oxygen gets
released, and you're left with this reduced
form of ceria.
You then add that to the water and carbon
dioxide, so when you heat all of them up together
- the oxygen given off by the dissociation
of water and carbon dioxide - gets absorbed
back into the ceria.
And that process gets repeated over and over
again, so eventually, you end up with syngas
that's completely oxygen-free.
At which point you can safely convert it into
fuel.
As amazing as this process is, the team who
discovered it has only produced a single glass
of kerosene thus far - but they estimate a
full-scale solar reactor could produce up
to 20,000 litres of jet fuel every day.
Above all else, they say "it's an important
milestone in the long-term process of developing
a truly sustainable alternative fuel future."
It uses infinite materials we already have
- and turns harmful ones - like carbon dioxide
- into actual useful resources.
What could be better than that?
Not much, I tell you.
Not much.
I think this is incredible, personally, and
I hope you guys agree - as always if you have
comments, questions, anything about this episode
you wanna say - leave it down below, and subscribe
here for more videos.